[Music]
so
have you guys heard of the new
playstation
cinco yeah aunt got it i heard people
are having problems
yeah people are having problems and
that's what this story is about so a lot
of people
specifically in the uk from this article
they there's a lot of uk customers
claiming that they
are not receiving their playstation 5
and instead they're receiving other
random ass
products what the delivery driver seems
to be pretty sketchy
oh [ __ ] um like one guy i would too the
demand for these things are [ __ ] nuts
and you can [ __ ] sell them on ebay
for like twice the price
for three times the price dude three
times the price isn't that what happened
four times the price
four
that's what happened with the ps3 how
much what is it but it's not
about the money it's about how limited
supply it is right so that's why like if
you sell it
and you it's gone then you have to wait
a long time before you get the next one
yeah you probably have to wait like six
months
they did that ps3 remember when it first
came out yeah
and the ps42 and the xbox one that's
true
it's yeah it always always happens and
the dreamcast
and the no i'm just kidding i missed the
dream i actually enjoyed
the dream kids dreamcast was sold out
dreamcast was the sega
like their last big release yeah the ps2
came out you're like
one dude they came up with like 25 games
and they're like yo we're calling it a
day
my dreamcast had like the least games i
had ever had i know it was so
frustrating bro because i was trying to
ride for sega i'm like
y'all got that bsd i watched
yeah and it was like after like okay i
got virtual fighter
virtual fighter i got the new virtual
cop you know what we were we were the
guys in the 90s who like everyone's like
hey i bought this thing called i bought
this stock called ebay we're like we
bought pets.com
this shit's gonna go crazy.com that's so
true
that's all around no well not that
company though
it got owned trust me but yeah so people
are receiving like
nerf guns what friars but this is
they're going through like oh [ __ ] you
know like amazon i mean oh wow
through amazon foot massagers they're
getting a george foreman girl which i
was shocked that they're even still
selling those oh yeah there's all types
of like george woman girls
are still coming out with like brand new
like fancier ones too they're pretty
cool because people are always going to
college
don't do not trust these amazon sellers
dude
you have to go if it's not the company
itself be so sc be so scared yeah
like whoever's involved in in switching
out the ps5
they are switching them out for like
heavier products too so it seems like it
is like this for example this one
uh they switched it out for a bag of
rice and another one that's
how much a ps5 right the george foreman
grill
over rice right yeah i'm true i mean i
guess someone's like kitty litter
and this dude doesn't even own a casket
yeah so how do you report this back and
be like i didn't do this
i got scammed yeah so a lot of people
are are
calling amazon and trying to figure out
what the [ __ ] is happening
and i like that you said this dude
doesn't even have a cat like if you did
have one he'd be like oh
well at least i got these
yeah i mean i could be pissed but [ __ ]
at least i could use it
but yeah like for example this other
dude though this other guy
it said he tweeted delivery guy marked
my delivery as
failed saw him go into the back of the
van outside my house and drove 20
feet down the road for the next delivery
went out
and had him get the box out of the back
and found the following tampering
qr code mashed and boxed open
this is another thing that people were
talking about it said delivered and he's
like oh [ __ ] i know i'm getting my
playstation 5 right now
yeah so he goes to outside he sees
nothing
and then he sees the delivery guy and so
he confronts him and he's like yo
do you have a playstation fire for me
and he's like uh no no don't have
anything and then he's like what's that
on the ground right there and then the
guy's like oh okay here you go
what yeah people are trying to resell
this [ __ ] or use it for themselves yeah
so it seems like it's a delivery guy
so it's not amazon delivery is it ups
is it was just we don't know no these
are the amazon the amazon sellers
they're the sketchy ones not amazon
company these are the
the resellers not the amazon drivers
could be the drivers i think it's the
driver
there's a lot of that too yeah but the
people who are leaving the rice bags and
stuff
it could have been the sellers yeah
they're selling right we're packaging it
how did the sellers get a hold
of the ps5 they know that that's the
whole thing they didn't so they're
shipping something
they just posted a product and they're
collecting a 499 dollar check got it
geez
so um when the ps4 are being sent like
the delivery driver knows what it is
because is it like
ps5 all over the box or is it
fortunately walmart when they were
shipping these it says ps5 on the box oh
that's so stupid
yeah i remember years ago when this
happened for one of the the systems i
forget which one
somebody had bought one off ebay
and it said like ps let's say it was
like a ps3
it was like ps3 box and it was just the
box but it said on the listing
box just that person didn't realize so
they paid like i don't know
a g for like just the box that's fine
that is such a [ __ ]
scam dude i got scammed like that too
so like on instagram i was um
i was looking at you know paddle boards
right and then
there was oh yeah it was like get two
paddle boards for 200 bucks it's like
it's we're going out of business it's a
super sale whatever
and then it's like i was like oh hell
yeah dude i need to get these inflatable
paddle boards
i didn't know that average price is like
in the hundreds
and maybe thousand so i was like oh cool
i'll get two for 200 bucks
and then in fine print i realized oh
[ __ ] they're just sending
the paddles so i bought [ __ ] ten
dollar paddles these
[ __ ] ass packs for like 200 bucks
right so i try to report it to paypal
i [ __ ] went and reported the ins and
i read all the comments the comments
like don't buy this shit's a scam i got
[ __ ] over
i was like oh no and then it's coming
from china
damn so like china's paypal was like no
they put a tracking number and i emailed
the company i was like nah i wanted
um i want to cancel this order they're
like we already shipped it i'm like
there's no way
i just ordered it an hour ago yeah and
they're like we can't we already shipped
it sorry buy these on the way
business model man what do you want me
to do you're breaking my [ __ ] balls
here
yeah and then so paypal all they do is
they check
the tracking number if it was sent
delivered or what right
so you put up a dispute and then they're
like nah it showed up to your house you
you can't get a refund really yeah man
that's not [ __ ] and i never even got it
too because i moved
so i don't even know if i have paddles
and my landlord never even told me
defensive paddles by the way
yeah that's 200 [ __ ] detachable
paddles the ones that you could get at
walmart too that come with the [ __ ]
inflatable raft it was that kind of [ __ ]
paddle
oh damn [ __ ] me man yeah
read the fine print i was so excited
especially if it's coming from china
yeah man i was trying to save money and
[ __ ] like yeah i'm gonna get two
inflatable
i was like oh i would just get two just
in case i go on a date and [ __ ] i could
get like two
oh that's right like you just pulled
over you're like yeah hell yeah you know
you inflate them and you go [ __ ]
paddle and [ __ ] yeah
now it's like i just i don't even got
the [ __ ] paddles dude
oh no that's really cute how you
imagined all that that's a door yeah he
imagined being there with his date and
he's like
yeah i'm gonna get the tube and be like
this it'll be okay there you go
there you go but yes amazon they have us
they
made a statement it says we're all about
making our customers happy
and that isn't that hasn't happened for
a small portion of these orders
we're really sorry about that and are
investigating exactly what happened
we're reaching out to every customer
who's had a problem and made us aware so
we can put it right
anyone who has had an issue with any
order can contact our customer service
team
services team for help and then they
report that some customers
that they have that this new site has
spoken to
they have been asked to wait 48 hours to
ensure that their deliveries don't
still turn up out of the blue and then
while others have been offered a
five british pound gift voucher this is
the story's from the uk so dude the
other [ __ ] about this stuff is the
people so there's a lot of parents right
now who
all their kids want i'm sure you're
aware of this their kids want for
christmas this year's
xbox the new xbox or the new playstation
right
well isaac wants the freaking thingies
virtual
oculus oculus oh he's bougie wow that's
that's nice
but you can get those at least that's
good isaac's isaac's the non-console kid
now he's like i hate consoles
does he have led lights on his pc no he
has that around his room
oh shoot is he streaming he did chores
just to
get the led yeah he wait chores for led
lights was like 10 bucks no he earned no
he paid for 40
wins okay he ended up earning his own is
he cooling his tower like does he put
all these extra things yeah
he doesn't know that [ __ ] yeah yeah wait
finish what you're saying oh yeah
so unfortunately there's there's uh
script
bots out there that are sniping all of
the orders as soon as they get stocked
so like
target.com gets a bunch right and then
because of covet you can't go in
physically and pick them up now
especially right now you could a couple
weeks ago so
these people are buying up all the stock
and so
and they're just reselling them like to
scalp so the scalpers market
those guys are killing it while all the
people who just want to get [ __ ] for
their kid they just want to get one for
their kid
and actually use the [ __ ] thing are
getting [ __ ] yeah it's crazy and this
happens every time and really the
retailers have done nothing about it to
try to fix it because they're selling it
exactly they're like hey it's going out
the door who cares exactly
but the people who can't get it for
their kids you know it sucks yeah
well it's getting to some kids right the
black market kids
yeah yeah yeah whoever is willing to
parents you've got 12 dad's a scammer
yeah and the other thing that people get
ripped off with is when they buy the
playstation 5 and they
take it out and they put it next to the
tv it looks ridiculous
it's kind of ugly isn't it i don't know
if you've seen it big storm trooper it
looks like a [ __ ] like
like museum sculpture it's like this big
oh wow it's like got a twisty
like looking it looks like a full
grocery bag you guys don't know
art bro i don't know dude that [ __ ]
looks cool to me dog
i don't know bro i prefer the xbox look
that [ __ ] looks cool
similar to the xbox wait lay it on it's
laid on its side bro lay it on its side
is it even meant to be on its side
that's pretty cool it goes both ways
apparently oh that looks [ __ ] weird
that looks cool dude
the xbox the white one that's kind of
cool the one xbox one i also don't know
anything about console
that's it's not that similar yeah watch
look let me see i think you're about to
get motivated it wasn't uneven like that
look at that uneven
xbox one is white the only thing that
they have similar is the color never
mind i take it back
modern promoted tiff's got mounted like
you have to say just so they know just
so they know
well i don't want them to think i got
with the new but the xbox looks very
simple which is nice
yeah isaac has this one so like this was
the last
console thing that he got yeah and he's
just like okay pc
he's right by the way because the you
can get the same [ __ ] games far
cheaper
and all the games suck on all those
anywhere right now i just play
minesweeper
no you don't i do i love minesweepers
are you still yeah that's cute
[Music]
so